hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm your Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
if you were worried about the Star Wars
trailers ruining so much for you no
never never get worried about such a
thing I think today we should watch the
story trailer featurette oh good I hope
I hope we get it all wrapped up in two
minutes or less let's find out what's
going on here
I flash back to when I was a kid but the
action figures inside do many unexpected
things they've taken characters in new
directions the visual stories with these
characters
Brian's approach to the story it's like
a real journey of discovery
first time shooting with mark first time
shooting with Daisy
first I'm shooting star wars movie and
that's a little sad like a dog
[Music]
Brian's wonderful personality is
although this film
as far as in other areas I just don't
know about our carry is the weird thing
that happens main building
into the nitty-gritty of working on it
naturally that level of it goes away and
you find yourself just focused on making
a scene work getting the shots and then
once in a while you're taking a little
break and sitting back
I'll make it a frickin story you don't
really appreciate about the marketing
the marketing of this movie is there
making it feel like an event beyond that
I feel like they're really honing in on
this is Ryan Johnson's movie behind the
scenes even at d23 what everyone says
about it in general and even the story
trailer you think you're just gonna be
like a bunch of like random interviews
but this whole time everyone's like yeah
this story shows really about how
awesome Ryan Johnson is as a director
well yeah I feel like the the double
meaning is it's about the story of
making this movie a little bit yeah
because one thing I like about the Star
Wars marketing specifically is they
always go out of their way or they at
least put extra content going out of
their way to show like yeah we're really
making this here's Ryan Johnson's
standing in front of the Millennium
Falcon that's been like constructed here
yeah yeah yeah and like proving that
they're really doing it for real and
that makes it feels so much more
tangible and so much more exciting I
don't really remember seeing a bunch of
things about with the force awakens they
like you kept hearing about what they
want to do with it I wasn't really
hearing like this is JJ Abrams it's baby
yeah you know just just get it right
yeah everyone's really making this feel
like this is like Ryan Johnson's like
guys I'm telling you what Brian Johnson
has in mind is gonna be so unique who
for what Star Wars his yeah I'm a big
fan of Rian Johnson so I love Roger I
believe that could be true and he seems
like a really genuine guy in these
moments you can never truly tell first
100% for sure whenever someone's on
camera whether or not how genuine or
real or whatever they are you can't even
tell with us that's just the fact of it
you've never met us in person you just
really have no idea what we're like the
documentary type of style of footage we
were getting in this featurette this
guy's just seems like a true fan who's
also a hard-working passionate film
exactly you know those last couple lines
of like it's a hop back and forth me
working on the scene and then holy crap
like I'm doing Star Wars yeah because I
imagine that sort of would feel like in
a weird way we're kind of experiencing
this journey of the last Jedi being put
together through the experience of Ryan
Johnson yeah this really feels like Rian
Johnson's the last check yeah yeah which
I'm excited about like I'm glad that
they're putting you know the faith in
him they were their bother yeah oh yeah
this got a big hand in making this movie
because you know it's easy to be cynical
about that kind of thing about movies
made by committee and stuff and yeah
yeah it seems like he is a sharp
creative dude who is leading this
forward and one thing I started to think
while watching this was sort of like
this doesn't look like very hard work I
think you must have to be a very good
link you must have to have a certain
level of skill and talent to manage all
this data you don't know where to put a
camera on this really expensive set we
may know it must be hard to look at when
you walk on a set and it's massive and
you got serious so much okay but we just
need this one shot first I think about
you know we think about filmmaking
sometimes and it's like you know you
start to think what could I do you know
like I can make a I can put a movie of
some sort together but then you look at
this and you're like oh no I don't have
to keep working for long attempted team
of people yeah you know you need a
community well let's say exact reason
why even if I hate a movie I would never
wish for it to not do well because
there's always a huge team Pia putting
this together and nobody tries not every
film is the Blair Witch Project alright
guys well we also have the last Jedi
tickets yes we do are quite secure
Naaman Oaks Thursday 7:00 p.m. whatever
that release date come say hello come
say hi to us we will be there and
running late and are quite only has
seven minutes of trailers we probably
won't be able to talk long because yeah
yeah but I'm also seeing it the next day
on IMAX Universal so and then the next
next day and 4dx
yeah yeah we'll see you guys soon
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification both we're on social media
we are on social media we have a page
and yeah we do